hello everybody my name is markiplier  and welcome to stranded deep a game  where you play underwater and that is  exactly all that I know about it oh I'm  on a plane this isn't underwater at all  no holy half  all right then I guess I need to survive  I'm gonna die I need to panic first I  got to get all my panicking out of my  system okay now that I got all that out  of my system I should be fine okay  I think I'm good I think I've got it all  out now I can calmly and rationally try  to approach this no I'm good I'm good  I'm all set  I found a shark I guess they don't come  out there in the world oh hi are you  doing you're a pretty one ain't ya oh  you ain't gonna bother nobody do you  want to be my friend I'm gonna eat you I  want a shark I want a shark like a prize  what the hell what what whoa whoa  whoa-kay  found a bug found a bug found about  found a bug I found a bug  oh my god everything is horrible I'm a  deaf okay gone